welcome back everybody our next guest's
delicious food content on social media
will leave you wanting seconds and
drooling he has almost 6 million
followers on tick tock and over 5
million on youtube and now his talents
have landed him on the new york times
bestseller list with his latest book
titled joshua wiseman an unapologetic
cookbook i spent the entire weekend
reading it cover to cover it's amazing
he's here welcome joshua wiseman
i have i know
all of my favorite pages dog-eared and
what was funny is i was about to write
to the producers and be like you know
what recipe i wish we could make
is the austin breakfast tacos and today
we are making
your the tacos that you wanted all along
they're happening
right here
right here
um what are we doing first okay so very
basic no competition but we'll keep it
very simple uh eggs in the bowl all
right so it's super super super easy a
lot of the time when people are making
scrambled eggs you've all heard the
stories right the rolls of scrambled
eggs you can't salt them beforehand you
can't whisk them too much they'll become
too aerated look at the end of the day
cooking is about making something that
you enjoy right so why would you be all
stressed about it just have fun with it
so pans on it's medium heat get a little
bit of butter in there if i'm moving too
fast by the way no are you kidding do
you want do you want to challenge me i
mean we i do we can go full speed yes
joshua okay
so butter's in the pan we've got the
eggs you can add a little bit of cream
if you want or you could just leave them
as eggs whatever
a little bit of salt yes i'm seasoning
them beforehand
get that butter mix around my eggs are
um are whisked and i'm adding them to
the pan and just let them cook a little
bit so essentially what you want is you
want to keep moving the pan okay so
while these are cooking drop your temp
all the way down the low because it's
going to keep going
and then while that's stirring
again you're getting looking really good
really yeah i'm also getting a nice arm
workout i'm not going to lie let's
double up that arm workout put your
tortillas in the pan can i borrow a
tortilla joshua you absolutely can
borrow a tortilla how many would you
like one two two please two done
in
so while our tortillas are heating
you'll notice this pan is a lot hotter
than this pan alright you're good there
i would pull those guys off okay plate
i can't remember if this is in fact they
feel so perfect and they're warm and
delicious and like little
warm babies tuck tuck
okay well then first step is egg goes on
okay so we have all these accoutrements
here oh i'm so excited i can't believe
this is happening i've been thinking
about this all weekend
i'm not kidding this has been my dream
you me and these austin breakfast tacos
i noticed
see what i love about these tacos is how
the bacon overhangs it almost yells that
i'm here and this is going to be a great
time okay so bacon's on we have all of
our accoutrements you can kind of add
this in any order but this is the order
that i would go in i would you already
know it's insane well i did read your
book front to back okay that's what
happens
every little detail a little bit of
jalapeno you can kind of alternate them
nice make them look pretty
how should i do my cilantro so i have i
have one quick tip so a lot of the time
people will just kind of like take leaf
by leaf but i think it looks a little
more natural if you take it from the
stem here and you leave a little bit of
stem and just prop it right on there
it makes like a little forest and there
is flavor in the cilantro stems that's
actually where the majority of the
flavor is almost all the flavor is in
the stem not in the leaf
sorry
and then
do we add a little
little cochita oh yeah just a little bit
you know now tell me about this salsa
sure okay so this is a really special
salsa i like to blend a little finer
sometimes but this is the salsa so think
of all the awesome breakfast tacos
you've gotten right and there's just
this there's this one salsa that's
jalapeno and it's just jalapeno but for
some reason it is so good what else is
in here it is literally just jalapeno
garlic oil salt that is it nothing else
and yet the flavor is undeniably higher
than any boxed canned salsa you've ever
had in your life you can smell it too
it's so good it's a really nice burst of
acid think and sink to that i love it
oh my god
what are you thinking what's going
through your mind right now having
dreamt about this moment for days on end
this is everything i was hoping it was
going to be
what i'm talking about
wow
and there is a spirit
of an extraordinary city in this dish
that you are truly honoring
that this whole globe let alone country
needs to enjoy so thank you for teaching
us this thank you and bringing a piece
of austin to our mouths and our hearts
and i'm just so excited to meet you
and work with you
i'm such a big fan of your book
and i would love um not to make this
creepy but can we please do this again
yes okay good done
done thank you thank you
joshua's book joshua wiseman an
unapologetic cookbook is out now and
available everywhere books are sold and
it is so wonderful get your copy if you
don't have it already we'll be right
back
[Music]
you